there's a tropical storm gaining
strength in the Atlantic that could
become a hurricane by late this week
meteorologist Stephanie Abrams from our
partners at the weather channel is
tracking this stuff it's a little early
for hurricanes in the year right Nate
good morning yes this one's unique as we
don't usually get our second name storm
until mid-july also it Formed far out in
the Atlantic where storms usually get
their start much later and the first
hurricane of the Season doesn't
typically happen until August the reason
for these anomalies low sheer and very
warm Waters both major factors in
tropical Cyclone development let's start
in the ocean all this warm water is
favorable for hurricanes in fact we've
had record warmth in the North Atlantic
and it's not just in North Atlantic
Oceans have also been warming here off
the coast of South America and this is
an indication that we have entered an El
Nino cycle all of this matters because a
warming Pacific typically leads to
Stronger upper level low winds over the
Atlantic which is bad for Hurricane
development so both water temperatures
and Shear will fluctuate in the coming
months and that's why the forecast is
for an average season with around 14
named storms for more in-depth coverage
on the tropics you can watch a weather
channel on cable or live on your
favorite TV streaming devices innate
things can change quickly so the time to
prepare is now
all right well let's just hope changes
for the better Stephanie Abrams thank
you